grab a beer and drink ur sorrows away
because we have the latest episode of
American Gods yes I know that doesn't
make any sense that's just how I do my
intros the episode begins with two
bloodhounds sniffing out the dead body
of an unknown woman this is followed by
shots of a mob and sheriff next to a
Chicago western junction sign hinting
that were somewhere in Illinois in the
past we'll later find out that this is
Cairo we then see a man being tied up in
a noose there's also a quick shot of se
McGowan the indentured servant who
brought the fairy folk and Matt Sweeney
to the Americas
notice how this shot is not at the
lynching it's daylight here the
widescreen aspect ratio suggests we're
looking at a God origin story but
there's not much to go off of here there
are also a lot of similarities between
this man and Shadowmoon both were hung
by a tree and had their ropes break back
in present-day shadow wakes up and
experiences a weird flashback while in
the mirror first his eyes turned red
similar to Odin's when he sacrificed his
car Betty and it's hard to miss but I
freeze framed his flash here and we can
see him back in the olden days which
then turns demonic shadow then takes the
razor to his neck unable to control
himself as we see in his reflection his
flaming head and gunshot wounds making
it clear that there is some connection
between him and the man who is lynched
at the beginning of the episode this
reminds me of what new media said in the
last episode she said she could feel her
previous versions inside her his shadow
starting to feel his previous versions
is he getting closer to discovering that
he is truly a God he's then visited by
the lynched man who says the words
memento mori
which translates from Latin to remember
death then we get this lovely scene
where Wednesday pisses on the plant old
Iktomi gave him he speaks in ancient
Norse and refers to the plant as eat
grass ooh which in Norse mythology was
an immense ash tree that connects the
nine worlds the gods would visit the
tree to have their daily assemblies and
its branches extend far into the heavens
shadow asked what's on the docket for
today but Wednesday tells him he has his
own matters to attend to
mr ibis asked him if he's comfortable
staying under the same room as the dead
which he responds as long as they stay
that way and I can't help but think of
his wife who is currently dead Sweeney
looks a little worse for wear having
arrived in New Orleans after we saw him
on the Christian rock bus
and that experience has turned him to
the bottle and he is a little one-on-one
with Jesus
notice the beaded necklaces which
suggests it's Mardi Gras Mardi Gras
[ __ ] I also love the little detail of
him having a sightseeing pass like he
went on a little tour on his own Laura
has arrived and she's looking for the
man who can bring her to life for good
remember two episodes ago Wednesday was
able to extend her dead body by
transferring some of Argus's power but
this was only a temporary solution if
she's going to be healed for good she'll
need to follow swingy to the Baron the
Baron is referring to Baron Samedi the
head of the guid aloha spirits of
ancient haitian vodou he can be found at
the Kok noir or black rooster which is
also the symbol of Mama Bridget's rum in
voodoo folklore Brigitte is the wife of
Baron Samedi and the only white voodoo
God she has her origins in Ireland the
Baron himself is the lo of the dead and
greets Sweeney by calling him his
brother but Brigitte over here steps in
and says the g'day Lua will not be
joining this fools war referring to
Wednesday but Sweeney ain't here for
that yes if the Baron can do anything to
help Laura and he agrees she can dine
with them at the chef's table but we'll
get to that in a bit I also think it's
fun that the rum he steals is crack and
rum an ancient Norse sea monster Ifrit
and salim argue over who the one true
god is when they're interrupted by
Wednesday looking for two gentlemen from
the city of Sodom this line has a double
meaning one that Sodom is an ancient
city in the Middle East and two it was
where the word sodomy comes from
something if written Saleem did in
season one they handover Wednesday's
spear and we learned that effort was
freed by Wednesday and feels that he
owes him hence why he's helping him out
and I just want to say I've been loving
the hidden somewhere in America signs
throughout the season the aspect ratio
has once again shifted to widescreen as
we follow mr. Nancy he checks his watch
like he's expecting something to happen
with this man Jamar good child meaning
he's related to Ruby good child who was
introduced last episode after scoring
some cocaine he's chased by the cops and
comes across the flaming head on a spike
of the lynched man solidifying that this
lynching took place in Cairo Jamar dies
of an opiate overdose yet has the same
bullet wounds and burn marks that the
Lynch man had shadow tells Ibis about
what he saw in the mirror and Ibis says
that's froggy James as
beard who makes people dream I did a
little research and this was an actual
lynching that happened back in 1909 to a
man named will James aka the froggy he
was implicated in the murder of a white
girl and where did this happen
Cairo Illinois this picture here is an
actual photo from the lynching in the
flashback the actors who play will and
the murdered girl are interchanged with
shadow and Laura again suggesting some
sort of connection we'll also says
remember you have to die
perhaps if shadows gonna figure out who
he truly is he must die and come back as
something new Ruby tells Reverend
Hutchins that with the death of Jamar
and her grandmother the streets will
come for her take everything she has she
needs to get out of there which the
Reverend doesn't want her to do
meanwhile Wednesday visits Elvis the
tallest Wharf in America in the hopes
that he can reforge his spear Elvis in
North Mythology is known to be a master
Smith he refers to himself as a builder
and I think it's safe to assume he's the
god of industry but industry in America
is dead the once great industrial towns
have seen industry moved to Mexico in
China hence why he now works alone in a
derelict Factory
Elvis inspects the spear but notes
Wednesday will need the services of de
Valen another dwarf who specializes in
runes the ones on his spear have faded
over time and have lost their strength
Duvall one is known in Norse mythology
as having fashioned the goddess Freya's
necklace crushing hamon back at the
Barons mama brigitte gives Laura a
little something to drink which
momentarily allows her to regain her
senses remember being dead she can't
taste touch or smell oh and maggots
there's also maggots Sweeney gets down
to business he wants his coin back and
asked the Baron if he can resurrect her
and the Baron agrees for a trade
shadow has a brief discussion with
mister ibis about why will James would
curse his own people he's referring to
how Cairo a predominantly
african-american neighborhood has fallen
on hard times
Ibis explains that will James felt
abandoned by his people they watched as
he was being lynched and did nothing
mister Nancy believes that it is Jack
well and Ibis who are the ones who have
been cursing the town to fuel their
funeral business
and mr. Nancy doesn't like that he says
that if Ibis is taking brown bodies he's
taking his worshippers and that cannot
be meanwhile shadow is transported back
in time
to the burning pike of will James notice
how all the people waiting for him are
african-american this is all connected
to what will James calls his burden he's
angered by the way his people have been
treated and grants those who have no
hope of peace while living the sweet
release of death then some embers fly up
shadows knows essentially cursing him
how we'll get to that but will states
that only when shadow walks with his
burden and shares it with the world
will he be released laura talks about
betraying shadow to the baron but her
real betrayal was telling him she loved
him in the first place the baron gives
her a concoction that will cure her but
something is missing blood infused with
love but he wants payment and how will
she pay Oh Laura meanwhile Sweeney has
finished his bottle of rum and enjoys a
nice dance from Brigitte who wants to
get it on but he can't get it up now
maybe it's the rum or the fact he's into
Laura
but since Sweeney still has this thing
for se McGowan and Laura looks just like
her maybe we'll find out where that
blood infused with love will come from
and then there's a lot of sex and in
their drug field hysteria Sweeney and
Laura bang back at the parlor Reverend
Hutchins conducts the funeral for Ida
good child
he tells Ruby he can no longer turn away
from the cruelty inflicted on his people
but also tells her that if she finds a
place where black people aren't treated
like they are in Cairo he'll come
running then mister ibis ass if anyone
else wants to say a few words and shadow
with flames in his eyes under the
control of will James tells the people
he welcomes the soul of death he also
explains how people during medieval
times knew the power of death and that
they worshiped it he was revered but
people have forgotten now shadow has
embraced this burden and has quote
shared it with the world and his
short-lived curse is lifted but what
does this all mean I think that it could
be foreshadowing shadows death this
season in order for him to be born anew
but I want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below
then shadow once again asked questions
he'll never likely get the answer to
asking what will James wanted from him
Ibis explains it was to be a reminder of
the shared pain of his people or that he
just wanted a beer but the scene ends on
Wednesdays piss plant aggressive which
has grown considerably in just one day
and after Loren Sweeney's mad night
Sweeney demands his coin but Laura isn't
cured she still needs to find blood
infused with love and considering how
everyone on the show is so messed up
love will be hard to find
perhaps Bilquis will come into play and
for the next little bit I'm gonna talk
about next week's preview so if you
don't want to hear about that Evert eye
eyes the preview picks up on the theme
of death with Wednesday telling shadow
the story of donar the great a thor like
character and it looks as though we'll
be going back to the 1920s for this my
guest from Wednesday's reaction here and
all this talk of death will learn how a
god-like donor will die for good if it
is the roaring 20s my guess is that
donar might be linked to the excess of
wealth at the time which later led to
the Great Depression mr. world warns
that a storm is coming
perhaps this storm and we see hands that
are likely to volunteer UN's on his
spear I think this episode will be
predominantly a cautionary tale that
will give shadow more insight into what
awaits him but we'll need to stay tuned
to find out thanks for watching everyone
as always make sure to subscribe and
give the video a like I'm planning on
breaking down more American Gods and
Game of Thrones next week you can also
follow me on twitter at things story
whitey until next time remember daddy
loves you very much